[Music]
and the last time you competed two
all-stars three how has the show changed
well the show itself has just continued
to grow and evolve but as much as it's
changed so much I still say the same
hello hi I'm Nicole hi Nicole I'm Jim
again shangela like I want to go back to
actually let's talk season three all
right okay what was your favorite look
from your first round on the show my
favorite look from season would be my
laqueefa look when I came out the
creeper in the fur and I had the leopard
cat suit and I had my toes hanging off
the edge of the shoe and they said like
wheat but I said that was my favorite
sometimes I don't even pay myself my own
money
HiFi dear maybe I should get some shoes
on my toes one hanging five inches off
the earth
cuz that was my first time doing look.we
for the post-mortem hope and she was
there every day who's very much a part
of you now let's see it truly
[Music]
what was your least favorite look pretty
much every other one no you know I think
my least favorite look would have to be
the Christmas Couture I mean let's just
hashtag epic fail okay I tried I was not
not even a seamstress I just didn't know
much about costuming at all the lights
were literally falling out of the skirt
and onto the stage while we were
standing there being judged and I was
trying like scoop them away with my foot
so just wouldn't get me it was horrible
and I had nightmares honey I was shocked
shucks what was your favorite lip sync
oh I would say believed by Cher that I
did with Carmen Carrera
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I just knew that I did not want to go
home I knew that I had more to give in
the competition and I felt like I was
finally getting you know my Juche I was
moving with the Jewish you know I was
going so it was the first time I did the
death drop you're the first one to do
the death drop on drag race thank you
show a girl some props halle-loo is the
bus still running favorite challenge
when we first go around
Oh favorite challenge would have to be
the space challenge and that was really
fun not only did Alexis and I do great
in the chat we also won Hey and and I
love working as an actor I've been able
to since drag race go on and work in a
lot of different projects on television
and film but you know that was one of my
starts in drag getting a little acting
gig going so that was in honey and then
of course we went to untucked outdoor
drink on somebody I feel myself from the
ground up last question about your
previous life on the show biggest regret
from that time my biggest regret I got
in my head a lot I was so focused on
wanting to deliver what I thought the
judges wanted I wasn't always giving
what I wanted to give so this time you
know I'm not I'm focusing on not doing
that and being so in my head I just want
to be free and live my say this is me
halle-loo
let's do it let's turn up let's have a
good time and make some moments
[Music]